You have to let me thank you Miss
Asteria. Asteria, wow it's a beautiful name
it's from my culture how did you do that
it's just a simple shift of weight
takes practice but i've been doing thisfor a long time
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my wonder woman 1984 video for
the post credit scene and the end of the movie
also talk about how this sort of dovetails with
what's going on with the justice league snyder cut
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos because it's christmas
we're doing an amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite part of the movie on the video
and what you want them to do with her during
wonder woman 3 given all the extra powers that
she had during wonder woman 1984. i know there
are a lot of questions now if she can fly in
this how come she's not flying in the present day
movies like batman v superman or justice league
i will address that when we get to that part of
the video but obviously careful for spoilers from
everything that happens during wonder woman 1984
because we'll have to talk about the entire end of
the movie not just the post-credits scene but just
starting at the end wonder woman realizes that the
dreamstone has taken her power in exchange for
granting her wish to bring back steve trevor
the way they accomplish that in the movie is
that steve trevor basically inhabits the body
of another character sort of replacing him in
his body when he's around anyone that looks at
him sees the original guy like when he looks in
a mirror but wonder woman sees him and hears him
as steve trevor he convinces her that the lie is
not worth it she needs to save the world and she
can't do that without her powers so she takes back
her wish steve trevor kind of dies again everyone
pressed f in the chat to pay respects to chris
pine she gets her powers back just as maxwell
lord and cheetah go to a presidential bunker where
he can transmit his power of the dreamstone to the
entire world so literally everyone all over the
planet will succumb to its power making wishes
wonder woman full-on flies during the movie as you
can see she can fly in the comics so we'll see how
they explain this to the justice league snyder cut
version of the movie because in the theatrical cut
in present day she never flies in any of those
movies i think that's mostly just a director's
choice like they were introducing her and slowly
leveling her up but if you think about it a little
she's been able to do this this entire time so
it does wind up being a little bit silly there'll
probably be a couple minor continuity issues just
because of what they decided to do with her during
wonder woman 1984 but zack snyder did say that she
has some really really badass action scenes during
the justice league snyder cut that are different
from the theatrical cuts so if you felt like there
wasn't enough action scenes during wonder woman
1984 which is a common complaint the justice
league snyder cup will be more of a straight up
superhero comic book movie like you would normally
expect there was a big invisible jet easter egg
here but it's actually her trying to replicate the
powers of her father zeus to make it invisible
the way he made themyskira invisible she said
earlier she made a coffee cup invisible but she
doesn't remember how she did it and because it's
invisible she can't find the coffee cup anymore
so it's actually a pretty op power that maybe
she'll wind up using in future movies and during
one of her flying scenes there is a scene directly
referencing a moment from the end of the first
superman movie when he's flying through the clouds
and you're hearing the voices of jor-el speak to
him about not being able to change the past the
course of human history before he flies around
the world and spins it backwards reversing time
the wonder woman version of the scene is when
she's flying to the island to stop maxwell lord
and cheetah and she hears the voices of all the
different people around the world calling out
making their wishes one of the other bigger easter
eggs early on is that one of the people who works
with maxwell lord is simon stag he's the business
partner that he gets rid of pretty early on but
she grabs the golden armor of asteria one of the
previous amazonian heroes who was out in the world
helping people she shows up in a second obviously
because that's part of the post-credit scene but
she uses the armor to fight the final boss form
of cheetah who's gotten powerful enough to hurt
her even when wonder woman is at full power
if you haven't seen any of the animated wonder
woman movies there are leveled up boss versions of
cheetah that can actually claw wonder woman's skin
out like her nails are strong enough to pierce her
skin whereas normally she can deflect bullets like
it's no big deal canonically wonder woman isn't
quite as strong as superman but she's like the
next closest thing to being as strong as superman
who is basically god tier powerful but cheetah
has made another wish to become an apex predator
which takes her to full comic book form cheetah
most of the movie after she makes her first wish
she's just kind of mid-level powerful but still
looks fully human she effectively wishes to be
just like wonder woman because she admires her
so much she's kind of a wonder woman stan at the
beginning of the movie wonder woman tries to save
her get her to take back her wish just like she
did like it's not worth it the lie isn't worth
it but she refuses to do it because of course
they're going to have their full-on boss fight
the special effects were okay and i think we
can all be thankful that they didn't go full
cats with cheetah we didn't have a cat's situation
this isn't a horror film but that's also part of
the reason why they did the fight at night to
hide the special effects as much as possible so
that you're not looking too closely and it comes
off a little bit better there's way more special
effects like this in the justice league snyder
cut for reference zack snyder did an interview
a little while ago saying that there are more
visual effects shots in the snyder cut than in
all of avengers end game so we'll see what that
actually ends up looking like in march when they
release all those episodes wonder woman doesn't
kill cheetah but she does beat the crap out of
her and eventually she does get her to take part
of her apex predator wish back but it's unclear if
she loses all of her abilities because she goes
back to looking exactly like she did when she
was still mid-level powerful funny enough though
she uses maxwell lord using the same trick that
she used on aquaman in justice league they turned
the joke from justice league into a big twist of
the movie she sneaks the lasso of truth under
him while he's busy transmitting to the world
she uses that to speak to the rest of the world
and show them the truth like no i'm not talking to
you i'm talking to all of them everyone's going
crazy all over the world because of the side
effects of the dream stone but also as part of
this a couple different nations are getting ready
to fire their nukes so the world is getting ready
to blow itself up in mutually assured destruction
they revealed during the movie that the dream
stone was created by the god of treachery go
figure that this is the end game of that within
the universe the lore behind the stone is that the
cultures that had it previously all annihilated
themselves and banished without a trace
so obviously this is what happened to them they
all annihilated themselves because they succumbed
to the dream stone she convinces maxwell lord that
he's about to lose his son and he pulls a wonder
woman taking his wish back reversing most of the
damage that he's done reuniting with him after a
small time jump i think it's assumed that he and
cheetah don't go to prison at least right away
because maxwell lord is running around free and
clear after this time jump reuniting with his son
and if wonder woman was going tohaul anyone to
prison if we're talking about christopher reeve
superman easter eggs because a lot of this movie
does feel like a christopher reeve superman movie
she'd be taking him to prison just like superman
flies lex luthor to prison at the end of one of
his movies the world chills out and everyone
starts celebrating all over the place and then
later after another time jump during christmas
wonder woman is walking around a town square
passes the man whose body steve trevor had
temporarily stolen he jokes about how his
friends make fun of him for his crazy 80s outfit
you have to remember it is the 1980s when this
movie is happening but it's a back to steve trevor
trying all the crazy outfits earlier in the movie
the parachute pants the fanny packs the members
only jacket does everybody parachute now what's
going on here then after another time jump
she ends the movie flying through the clouds
like superman the way they visualize her flying
scenes are a little bit like christopher reeves
superman flying scenes obviously very different
from the way henry cavill's superman flies just
the way they visualize that but again that's
another conscious design choice by patty jenkins
to reference the christopher reeve superman she
hears a siren in the distance then flies off to
help and that's basically what she's doing until
present day when the events of batman v superman
and then justice league pickup but then during the
post-credits scene somewhere else in american city
after another time jump a pole breaks and almost
crushes the baby but a woman in blue stops it like
it's no big deal without breaking her step and as
the woman rushes to thank her for saving her child
she turns around and it's revealed to be linda
carter in the flesh who's playing asteria the
person who wonder woman's golden armor belonged to
before her the amazon before wonder woman who had
gone out into the world to help mankind she says
it's no big deal just a simple trick of shifting
your weight and i've been doing this for a long
time sort of metaphorically winking at the camera
and it's meant to be a big reference to linda
carter's wonder woman tv show like yes asteria
has been helping people in the dc eu within the
continuity of the movie for a long time because
she's ancient like the other amazons but also in
real life linda carter has literally been doing
the wonder woman thing for a long time then they
go back to the credits just implying that asteria
linda carter's character might show up again
during wonder woman 3 or some other future
movie if they want the whole thing with the linda
carter cameo is that patty jenkins said during the
first movie she had kind of wanted to do it but
it just didn't work out the way she wanted to
so when they got to the second movie when she knew
she was going to do wonder woman 1984 she made a
big deal about getting linda carter in the movie
and linda carter said that she would always be
happy to cameo in one of the wonder woman movies
as long as they wrote a good part for her so
that's why they created the asteria character
in the universe of the movie were christopher
reeve to still be alive in present day it sort of
be like then doing a henry cavill superman film
then saying the christopher reeves superman is
just another version of superman from another
earth and he comes in cameos at the end of one
of superman's movies like i've been doing this
for a long time and they sort of answered some of
the other big questions people had going into it
like what's going on with lassoing the lightning
bolts she really is lassoing the lightning bolt
but she's also full-blown flying at the same time
but if you haven't heard about patty jenkins and
gal gadot talk about wonder woman 3 they did say
that that would be set during present day but they
haven't signed patty jenkins to the movie yet so
they're not making it yet it's just a theoretical
movie at this point and she said that she wouldn't
do wonder woman 3 until after she does her star
wars movie the rogue squadron movie which actually
is confirmed to be in the distant future after the
events of the new star wars movies they released
a teaser for that back during the disney investor
meeting so she'll start talking more about her
star wars movie in the next couple of years as she
starts to make it but that's not going to premiere
till december 2023 so it's still a couple years
away the real future of the star wars franchise
is actually in the disney plus series there are
10 new star wars shows coming in the next couple
of years i've been doing a bunch of videos about
that so i'll link them in the description the
whole thing with the justice league snyder cut
is that zack snyder confirmed that it was going
to premiere in march it's supposed to be i believe
four episodes they're going toair in four
different parts just because it's going to be
over 4 hours long but zack snyder said that he'd
be releasing another really big trailer in january
sometime and they start spinning up and promoting
the movie so we'll learn more details about that
they might change the release date just a little
bit but if you have any of the big questions
about the end of the movie or any big easter egg
questions just write them below in the comments
the next really big thing that's happening is
that the marvel one division episodes are going
topremiere january 15th i'll be doing episode
videos for that so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see those when
they drop there's also a bunch of other stuff
that's going to be happening between now and
then too everyone click here for that new star
wars rogue one prequel trailer video and click
here for all my mandalorian season 3 episodes
and season 2 episode videos thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe merry christmas!